[Music]
in road rage news uh we were just
talking about that who submitted by it
chi balls itchy bound I don't get out a
little Japanese boys name Ichi bitching
balls
my name is Ichi bars a 68 year old man
clung to the front of a moving school
bus clung to the Oh like no I you ain't
leaving [ __ ] children so this man his
name is Luverne Luverne that's why he's
mad 68 years old he's a retired former
teacher that's why he's even more man
matter from Baltimore thank you
Oh made that [ __ ] up oh really
where is Baltimore Maryland Marlon I
knew that in Baltimore late I'll make
sense so far in the burn mo mad about
more apparently that was a student in
the school bus that threw a Gatorade
bottle at Liberty locked up and then
that's when he just got pissed and he
went up to the the bus he started
banging on the door the bus driver
wouldn't open it and then he went around
and he started cleaning onto the school
bus and then the driver started was
double alright and then the driver
started driving off yeah and he knew
that Laverne was on the bus he's driving
maybe I'm gonna show you a video that
bus drivers lose his job
yeah and go to jail because I many times
his murder it's interesting because it's
been reported that the bus driver has no
charges but Laverne did get in trouble
so bus drivers should have charges
though I agree he was endangering about
the kid that assaulted the man and
through a gate or a bottle he was
suspended for three days that's it yeah
well what else did you want some caning
no you said yes can they do get a
spanking Oh
realistically what else can do
minutes in the room with the person that
assault I've been waiting for this
moment
yeah because apparently just kept
banging banging banging and then the
video happened and you guys will see
that and then after the video stopped
the bus driver pulled up somewhere and
then that's when Laverne came around
again with banging on the door he
finally pried it open he went inside the
bus he started yelling at the bus driver
so thought about the kid now apparently
the kids like there was a witness in
there like a grandma that has three
grandchildren and that school bus saying
that a lot of kids just got really
scared they all went to the back of the
bus and we're hiding under that bunch of
[ __ ] [ __ ] ass [ __ ] got all
[ __ ] gatorade you better stand up
[ __ ]
true apparently it was an investigation
they found out [ __ ] threw the bottle and
now the kid was suspended for three days
so here's the video clash it's been 15
minutes in there oh man oh look at this
guy well he does look like a little burn
I am here we go
looks like a PE teacher says yep NR a
hat whoa Danny's tough I like that guy
he's just capture I think yeah yeah
laughing what are you saying this bus
driver I should lose this job though
that's very dangerous yeah that's kind
of funny-looking how can we get off the
bus if you're driving [ __ ]
maybe he's going really slow she can't
be driving under dangerous conditions
yeah I wouldn't want my kid to be in
that bus with that bus driver imagine
he'd like slip fall and then he runs
over the sink and traumatize now yeah
what the [ __ ] that guy should lose his
[ __ ] job protecting the kids from the
bear all he got to do is Park it chill
and call the cop
yep that's the responsible thing to do
oh man I think I want to just kept
driving too though yeah it's a laverne's
attorney was saying that
Laverne was left with no choice because
it was either try to get under the bus
and go on top of the bus or just not get
on the bus at all and don't react with a
[ __ ] bottle you know kids
dumb [ __ ] well Hugh thing also he was he
was concerned for he felt a
responsibility to kill them and deal
with that issue because it's a safety
issue the fact that the kid was throwing
a bottle outside of the window because
it's like what else could he be throwing
next so that's where Laverne felt
responsible to go because he was also a
retired teacher so it's maybe he should
channel that in he was just like oh I
gotta talk to that kid or whatever even
and it's a lawyer we're just saying it
does make sense though because if you
take the bus even if you stick your arm
out the tea-table hey everyone keep
their arms inside the bus keep all limbs
inside so like it's one of those make
sense if a kid does something you have
to kind of tell the policy all over here
I feel like if a kid threw a Gatorade
bottle at my car I probably would just
follow the bus to the school and then
jump the kid you guys you don't know if
he was sexually assaulted by the teacher
and he decided to get him back with the
Gatorade bottles and that's hella dork
he doesn't look like a sexual attack
girl he's retired you don't know who's
retired from that school sixty-eight I'm
just saying man we've been reading a lot
of news about the rape teachers all the
flute teachers maybe he was coming on
some flutes that's where my headway look
at poor Laverne all right I can't say
anything about a guy that looks like a
walrus love burned oh right he does
that's the spirit he looks like a
friendly walrus I'm sorry Laverne I just
want to draw a little monocle to talk
though let's let's pull it back a little
bit just a little bit you know kids
especially if they're high school I
don't I'm assuming they're high school
yeah they don't mention what grade but
kids are [ __ ] kids are [ __ ] dick
junior high they might be yeah I was a
big dicker like for real
and we because I said they're dicks
oh okay I was like what thought you were
high I was a really bigger bigger
dude me and my friends and we would sit
in the back of the bus because everyone
knows in the back of the bus is where
you [ __ ] around right because the
teachers always sit in the front so we
would phone the back and then we would
purposely target cars that were
convertibles and they would get gum and
throw it inside so that like they can't
catch and then it's all melts and it's
all [ __ ] up oh you guys hate it
sitting in the back of the bus
cuz then it would take you forever to
get off of it I just want to get off the
[ __ ] bus I mean I didn't want to be
with the teachers plays from the
teachers and your teacher's pet I mean
we don't we don't have pictures on my
bus public school bus stuff we just had
the bus driver oh I'm thinking field
trip yourself one time I saw this dude
his name was Dale ray Moore and this
other guy named Chen oh and this other
dude named Victor Vasquez Wow so diverse
yeah well Sacramento baby pulling them
all wow we're all now twenty nine thirty
years old but these dude it was so funny
because they were friends and they got
this huge fight started beating up Del
Ray one dude was crying I thought we
were friends
and they bought all grabbed their
backpacks and they all walked home
together it was yeah it was very weird I
was like what happened he just couldn't
stop laughing though because it was
weird because they just beat his ass and
then they got up they all started crying
that was the guy way to do it but the
crying part was the weird oh that's the
we yeah I'm excited cry be sort of
walking away that's people from sac I
guess I guess it's weird interesting yes
anyway so Laverne got charged with
disturbing the peace and destruction of
property uh and that's about all we know
I think he [ __ ] up once he was like ah
he seems like a pretty strong guy yeah
you shouldn't have gone to that was
ranged he probably beat his wife in his
earlier years he's aggressive yeah he's
pretty
yeah he's a man that slams the car and
forces you and yells to stop you know he
got a little bit of anger problems there
that's when I listen but anger problem
wasn't going to be a pastor anymore cuz
I was gonna anger problem I had anger
issue like that where I just got fed up
with this one [ __ ] kid did he throw a
Gatorade bottle at you no but he kept on
trying to be funny and so I hate those
kids so literally I just flickered hit
no that's a refer another job but then I
was just sitting there and I just went
oh but I punched the desk super [ __ ]
loud and it's got dead quiet and as I
say what you're doing to me making me
very angry
I liked it I was like I can't be a
pastor this is not kids or tickers yeah
two years of that no that yeah it's just
Karma because we probably made people
feel that way
hope you guys enjoyed that episode of JK
news make sure to stay connected because
we're constantly updating our social
media so follow us at JK films for
Instagram and at JK films for Twitter to
watch more videos click right over here
[Music]